[Applause]
like toffee confusing good bunny very
nice meat yeah likewise good to see you
too
hi fantastic hi tommy tommy good to see
you
hey welcome and your criminal crime out
of oxford is that right obviously
the bee's knees the best cooks i've got
off yeah yeah yeah sorry
um now none of you've been anywhere near
professional kitchen before um this is
nothing to do with the flash [ __ ]
dinner party
i don't give a [ __ ] how many thousands
of acres and land you own
yes um tonight my standards yeah
my organization quite frankly i don't
care whether you hate my guts between
seven o'clock and eleven i just want it
right
now you've all been shown how to do the
startup yeah yes and
it's pretty straightforward there's only
two things on the plate it's a prawn
toast with a cucumber salad
okay i'm going to show you once more
together that way there's no excuse for
fuck-ups
okay absolutely good man okay double pay
prawns
okay first thing we'll do is break down
the prawns okay
so we just pulsate the machine
half the egg whites in okay yeah
so we're making basically a really nice
prawn mousse yeah
corn flour in it that just gives it a
little bit of body
okay which in a way that it stops it
from sort of disintegrating when it hits
the heat
yeah we're just spreading the puree of
prawns
onto the toast yeah from there here we
go
sesame seed giant sides as well okay
and then here we go the most important
thing about cooking these sesame seed
toast is making sure the pan's nice and
hot yeah okay
right four cups table three yes four
spoon toast
four lemon soul and papaya four plum
tarts yes yes
and all the four killers table six four
prontos four lemon salt and pepper yacht
four plum tarts
barney yep what did i just say there
sort sword shift in here
yeah exactly you didn't hear so work
with your ears open okay
my name's barney i'm really into british
game for instance
rabbids really lean meat really good for
you and most importantly they've all
really really tasted
my name's tommy when i'm cooking i
really like to find things that people
won't often have had so i got really
into buying the cheaper cuts of meat the
more interesting things that could be
really fun to serve people
i'm sophie my favorite thing at the
moment is scallops wrapped in bacon
they're absolutely amazing and a kind of
prominent tomatoey sauce being the only
girl i think it's probably my
responsibility to bring a bit of you
know flair
my name's ollie i'm a good cook i'm cool
under pressure
i think i'm good enough i know i'm good
enough actually when i say so myself
people say i look like him i could
become the next golden man
who knows oxford's a very competitive
place people do everything competitively
i won't settle for anything but the
absolute best it will win i mean
no question about it
soppy sophie i may not have any [ __ ]
a levels but i'm not going to argue
right now okay what are you doing
okay i'm doing one set i don't know why
i'm doing one set by itself okay one
portion is going to get us nowhere yeah
so i need to do three
start again and do four portions
together four three the what
12. there we go
right barnard you have the first ticket
big boy how long um five minutes left
uh barney yep the oil stone cold
bring the pan here it's stone cold so
it's like an oil slick there's like
exxon valdez on there come on get the
pan heart
huh what happens if it's cold barney
we'll send it back chef that's right
yeah just you can use one of my pants
we'll just do one of mine for yours
honey okay come on
yeah cheers [ __ ] you now don't start
giving me that [ __ ] yes
it's not a race and stay in control what
you're doing chef
don't start giving me that [ __ ] yes
okay top of the plate 12 o'clock the
cucumber has been cut into ribbons then
marinated in rice vinegar sugar
sake and sesame seeds simple and then
the toast
right four plates come on i can't just
serve yours and his at the same time
four plates
sell this table clean your plate this is
your food leave him he's fine
right you're happy with that would you
pay for that yeah sure that's very nice
come on let's go up we go
gently gently gently gently service
why are they all look at that i'll get
you no come on barney i'm [ __ ] i mean
come here a minute you eat that for me
let's do it that way then no
seriously now because you're an educated
man eat it right
okay so why wouldn't you eat it oh chef
i haven't seen it you haven't seen it
open your [ __ ] eyes big boy
you've got to check barney chef i know
i'm not having a good day
you're clearly not on the verge of
yeah are you happy with them yeah good
thanks for that it took you long enough
thank you
let's go
did you enjoy your stuff i wasn't overly
impressed
no i've got to be honest go on tell me
why not um
well to me it just tastes a little bit
greasy in very sesame seedy i couldn't
really taste the pork i really thought
that was like a
dumpling prawn underneath that toast
yeah and i really couldn't taste it
how much did you pay for that ball
bearing on your tongue you don't need to
bring that into it
sorry but i mean you're talking to me
about an educated palette
and you've got yours cake and [ __ ]
shrapnel sorry put your tongue out
no show me your ball bearing you've got
a ball bearing on your tongue and your
palette is
[ __ ] end of story on your tongue
are you what years ago i used to
occasionally get there well here we go
good evening guys
how are you very well thank you welcome
back to the f word it's lovely to be
here again i'm as surprised as you are
you've got a second series so
congratulations to you [ __ ]
absolutely they made a lot of changes i
would have thought they'd start with the
house but anyway
anthony was busy
[Laughter]
the food here the food is so far it's
been very good so you're happy we are so
far quite happy thankful for that
apparently we're playing this evening i
know everyone's paying that's the idea
you know that what's what's going on
seven quid for those seven queens
[ __ ] hell when you said play up at
150 tops no but [ __ ]
extract that from 18 million [ __ ]
i've come up with a great way of
recycling these unwanted celebrity
cookbooks what are you going to do
will you come with me okay i need you
for 30 seconds
just to come into the bathroom with me
30 seconds i'm not back in a minute
all these [ __ ] cookbooks are flooding
in i had to think of some way of
recycling them and using them
what do you think of that you know what
this happens why this upsets me yes
because sometimes you come to the toilet
not to go to the toilet
well i can't knock one out while he's
staring at me judging me
hey have a look at this one this one
you'll really enjoy
you know what that is the scariest
freddie krueger
the freddie kruger of the kitchen and
the last one i don't know i don't know
if i can go
i'm sorry but look what a way of
utilizing unwanted celebrity cookbooks
have a look at that
oh last scene
killing his career on a talent show chef
shouldn't be on tv no
listen it's all done with bottom safe
inc you know that yeah
leave a little bit try to get the bag
here you go how's that working for you
[Music]
i thought the texture of the cucumber
with
against the texture of the prawn taste
it was it worked really well
it wasn't dry it was succulent moist
prawns
really really nice thoroughly enjoyed it
jean-baptiste guys come over please
results yes for the starters
let's go ollie okay right how many
customers are playing
27 27 of pain yeah what is 23 that i'm
not paying 2300 pain yeah why so many
the main the main problem is a bit
greasy a bit greasy
barney what do we talk about they agree
no no grease and why were they greasy
there's too much all in the pan no going
into a cold pan
i saw you hunting times put them into a
cold pan
so we're going from one extreme to the
other this is just a [ __ ] prawn on
toast that's all
yeah you know i'm really sorry but 23
customers not paying is a [ __ ]
embarrassment
clear down start thinking about the main
course and we're not going to keep
customers waiting that long for the main
course
i don't care how many [ __ ] degrees
we've got we're not going to let them
wait that length of time next on the
menu i say something i thought i'd never
say
it's enough to make anyone turn [ __ ]
vegetarian for god's sake
the brigade get to work on the main
course lemon sol and papiyat
and michelle collins takes me on in the
recipe challenge but she doesn't even
know what she's cooking
puppets pie cottage pie mine's a
shepherd's pie oh for god's sake
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word away now four
cups table three
yep four lemon soul table three barney
your table let's go
seoul in sauce sophie yes
away now four cups table ten four lemon
soul and papaya away let's go
time for the main course a mouth
watering lemon sole and papillot with
red chard
and jersey royals
[Music]
lemon salt for me one of the most
flavoursome flatfish
twice as much flavor as the dover salt
and more importantly half the price
skin side down skin just
nip at the end grab it like you're sort
of almost pulling hair
and let the knife do the work season
dill dill and fish go brilliantly
because it's got that really nice sort
of fennel flavor
that sort of aniseed flavor and just
roll
almost like a sausage leeks
carrots spring onions garlic
it's a very delicate dainty fish this so
we don't want to
overpower the garlic and then something
to sort of
wake them up a little bit thyme
rosemary the time goes brilliant with
the leeks
and the rosemary goes fantastic with the
carrots
baking paper if i had to put them on my
board
like that then they're going to curl up
so i turn the paper
almost inside out add veg
we're looking for a bed like a nest of
vegetables season
and then just drizzle generously with
olive oil
it looks delicious now it's not even
cooked second piece of paper
that goes over the top wrap
you get the top right hand corner and
you just fold
that over
and then over again fold and push
and just follow it round fold and push
we've left almost like a little snout
white wine
what the wine does as that soul is
steaming there
it makes a really nice aroma with the
vegetable the olive oil and keeps
everything really nice and light and
fruity
seal pan on there and push down
and look just seals the paper
hot oven 20 minutes
and this is the bit of magic
in and just look
oh look at that absolutely delicious and
a perfume of the herbs
extraordinary soul on papillon done
now barney chef yes sophie ollie tommy
i'm trusting you guys to get this
absolutely spot on you know that
yes yeah because this gets cooked in the
oven and the surprise the excitement is
when it hits the table
on papiad slightly souffled and that
lovely surprise
in front of the customer will open that
bag yes yes let's go guys yes
don't forget the wine in there as well
good job yes herbs
one in last yeah first thing to do is
is to get four one two three four and
then you know
you work four times faster simple
mathematics so
one of those you've got two there now
it's fine but on there on there stage
stage and then wrap them all at the same
time
thanks a lot let's go good
come on come on come on come on what
time it is no no no but put them in the
oven they look at your watch
oh my god nice and tight quick
yeah okay so um which level can we
we don't sit there and discuss timings
open close straight away
with the soul i'm serving potatoes with
mint and charred with garlic
now that's loads before getting it back
off
a little bit more seasoning yeah and
then all we do is just
toss it that's all toss it
it cooks so quickly that's it so we take
it off the stove
off the heat okay see how it breaks down
yeah
yes and we just wilt it very quickly
watch
watch please there that's it cooked
done the lightness of the chard with the
jersey royals is a perfect accompaniment
you know that
see how we still got texture in there so
come on please let's go
right hello yes taste that tell me what
you think it needs that's normal
yep more garlic there's not even salt in
there either
can we have the chard cooked nicely with
a bit of texture yes
and the reason why it looks like there's
nothing in the bowl because we're
overcooking it
it's like a spinach leaf like a wilted
lettuce sleeve nice texture there
as well yes put the pan down please
straight off there into there and out
give it a little shake
okay then back into your pan like that
and then from there into there
okay
my mission to get the nation cooking
sunday lunch has thrown up some real
challenges
none bigger than the family without a
dining table
[Music]
we never sit down any together you know
the three boys uh
liam jordan and luke they're all playing
football at different times
during the week they're coming in from
school and it's
everything's rushed so when was the last
time we actually sat down together as a
family
um all together literally yeah all
around the table three boys
and yourselves i can't remember it's as
long ago as that so
where would you eat we have like a
little bistro table now
family of five table could only fit two
yeah
yeah every night we're out um and our
work shifts so there's terms out on
nights
the only way around this to eat around
the table is to come up with something
like a stew or casserole right so yeah
prepare it on a saturday
to reheat for a sunday
first off we've got to get a table
[Music]
we're happy with this one yes yes it's
quite nice i think you go well in the
kitchen
now that's just a really nice chunk
of braising steak can i just say though
if i was buying this yes
um i would be put off if there was a bit
of fat like that if there's no fat on
there it will go dry
so you've got to look for the fat okay
whilst mums do that i want you to do the
vegetables
okay first of all shallots take off
this that's the root but we don't take
the whole thing off because
if you cut the whole root off all the
juice will come out of it and then
you'll start crying
now what the flour does all right it
coats the meat
and so when the casserole is cooking it
gives it a little bit of body
and the nice thing about this casserole
you know that is the fact that you don't
have to be precious with it
i've noticed that i thought you were a
bit rough yes well nothing with a bit of
rough trust me you just take your
braising steak don't be scared of this
because you're putting color on it
and color means flavor
yeah i'm gonna put in some really nice
smoked bacon i'm gonna smell that
try bacon you don't like bacon oh
luke i thought you were a chef my man
what i'm gonna do now is cook that bacon
and then we're gonna put the vegetables
on top of it
then at the time bay leaves tomato puree
the brown meat
and finally the stock looks
if you think that's tasty now just
imagine what it's gonna be like in two
and a half hours time
so just after 15 minutes preparation
tomorrow's lunch is sorted
so this is this is it every sunday this
is this is exactly what it's like every
sunday
are we dinner prepared they'll have a
nice one well that's the most important
thing
we're here now having a great time
supporting luke and the nice thing about
it is that everything's done at home
lift
[Applause]
all right guys you ready yep let's go
we're two minutes away from getting
everybody around the table for the first
time in a long time
chin chin chin cheers it's not that
difficult is it really
no absolutely no i'm really confident
i'll be able to do it myself okay
all of you around the table i want you
to make me
a promise that you will continue to do
this every sunday yep that's a promise
where's the two-seater joe see it's gone
for good man's taking it away yeah
dragon boat god
fantastic
right ollie and tommy three each away
again now yes one take with three three
on table one
three table five please lolly you got
table one let's go
tommy you've got table five listen tommy
three and three let's do
three yes yeah service please
finally i'm gonna do your potatoes as
well okay what
is your spoon olive oil you need one
more
[Music]
potatoes yeah can you do me a favor and
do your own
and stop depending on each other to do
because that's what's confusing just do
your own pan
one each one for five one for four end
of story
there's one more table to come please
okay
now you can see it's enough for five in
there easily yes
that's right it's got texture there it's
lightly wilted
taste it please understand what we're
doing yes let's go
[Music]
service please we're going to 14 yeah
[ __ ] listen to me please yes
my handmade pigs have been really
fattening up nicely over the last couple
of months but now
the clock is really ticking
the pigs won't be around for long but
while they're with us i want them to
have the best life possible
constant access to water every day they
can drink up to five liters each
a nutritious breakfast of wholesome
grains
[Music]
and these posh pigs have their poo
cleared up twice a day
the 70 square meters in their pig pen
gives them plenty of room to play
[Music]
these two are very social animals who
love each other's company
see you later
and the pigs spend more than 70 of their
time sleeping but the good life
doesn't come cheap the way we're keeping
these pigs
is turning out to be very expensive in
terms of just on what they eat
every week is on average between sort of
35 40 quid a week on feed for both of
them
um and so far we spent just over two and
a half grand
on getting them where they are today
they don't look like they've got to
worry in hell to be honest
what a happy life for a piece of bacon
christine co who i bought my boxers from
is a passionate advocate of free-range
farming
but her concerns go way beyond the
flavour of meat and she's come to show
me how some commercially farmed pigs are
kept
so i'm fascinated to see how a real
commercial pig is sort of reared
okay sure look at this yeah
most british pigs are reared in
commercial unis like these now you see
how many pigs are in a very small area
god they've got food constantly which is
which is good and they've got
water and then the whole aim is to just
fatten up so don't go outside
no they don't i mean an indoor weird pig
does not go outside you see
fairing crates are used to stop the sows
lying on the piglets but
it's not natural in the sense that
normally
a sow would build a nest she would make
sure that the piglets were
were in a particular place two-thirds of
pork in britain is imported from europe
and it seems that their standards can be
much lower
the sours are literally put into rows
and rows where they can't turn around
these are not legal now in the uk all
day all day
i mean they can just about lie down but
they can't turn around
yeah that's gross look at that how many
are crammed into an area
and bear in mind that we import 858
000 tons of pig meat into the uk
yeah again 70 of all of the imports
would not
meet uk welfare standards
but there's another unpleasant practice
which is common in the uk and europe
tail docking
so what they do is because pigs are
social animals and they like to have
lots of space to run around as we've
seen the girls doing
if they're in cramped circumstances and
they get bad habits and one of the bad
habits is they chew each other's tails
so so what what they do is they actually
take the tails off to save them chewing
them
oh dear flipping egg but the most
disturbing thing for me
is castration it's rare in the uk but
common in holland and denmark
my god i mean just getting a ball in the
nuts by playing football or
getting kicked in the nuts imagine
getting them cut off
it looks painful but if it's done in
accordance with eu guidelines then
piglets over seven days old
should be anesthetized as bores get
get older and their hormones start
coming through then the
smell of their urine is very very strong
so you get that
with a load of of sort of nearly mature
bores the smell is going to be horrific
so they cast some producers think this
smell can tame the meat
but whatever the reasons i'm still
shocked by what i've seen from europe
um it's enough to make anyone turn
[ __ ] vegetarian for god's sake
and i've always sort of knocked
vegetarians and vegans for
you know missing out on you know the
most amazing flavor you get from meat
but you can see why so many people
change instantly
i didn't think he'd be quite as shocked
as he was he seemed
really taken aback and it touched him
[Music]
no way would we ever treat you like that
you know
hey good girls
hey
love the flavor of the dill went very
well with the
with the fish the vegetables were
fantastic
just thought it was a really good uh
good dish i enjoyed it
but it wasn't amazing good flavor was
simple
simple was nice subtle flavors
and uh loved it loved it i paid for it
where is it okay guys let's go sophie
barney let's go okay
gordon ollie come over please result to
the main course yes
yeah he went you went very well 38
upping so only 12 non-paid yeah
and what do they say the 12. um
slightly too watery but that was the
main complaint when they really love it
actually
it's a delicate dainty sweet fish yeah
yeah
38 playing 12 not playing yes let's
[ __ ] do it on this one let's look at
that
yeah let's definitely make up for the
next 12 yes okay good well done yes
is that lumpy next on the menu michelle
collins tells me about her food issues
guys what did you weigh then about five
and a half six stone
you're joking yeah [ __ ] i can't
imagine you being five and a half stone
my god the brigade learned how to make a
fantastic plum tatan
and jonathan ross gets to grips with
eels
don't upset him we're about to kill it
there you go
welcome back time for the recipe
challenge now michelle collins is going
to take me on with her mum's recipe
yeah her very own cottage pie good
puppet pie cottage pie
mine's the shepherd's pie oh for god's
sake right we're both doing cottage pie
yes no we're doing shepherd's pie
oh for [ __ ] sake hoodie shepherd with
lamb no
well we can change it it doesn't matter
it's home cooking it's what i'm doing
i'm doing what you're doing well i'm
doing chef's pie oh [ __ ] hell
michelle collins listen to me huh we're
both making [ __ ] cottage pie
with beef shepherd's pie is made with
lamb all right
okay good fine when's the last time you
made this well
to tell the truth i did a bit of a dummy
run yesterday
ah and i did two i did one with tomatoes
and one without the tomatoes
really and my daughter hated the one
with tomatoes is your daughter gonna be
one of the blind tasters today
i did ask her but she didn't want to
come she never heard of you damn
[Music]
not that knob on the karaoke machine
again you weren't on the x factor then
yeah you're [ __ ] joking aren't you no
no no no no rumor has it okay michelle
that he doesn't charge you for when you
go for dinner bloody does charge me
i can't believe you paid for that [ __ ]
seriously he's not a chef
he's a waiter so enjoy your food don't
you
i do yes you don't have to be that
conscious about what you eat surely you
know i'm an actress
and i did have sort of food issues when
i was a teenager i was
anorexic oh really and uh and it's
something that i think you don't ever
really get
over and how did you get out of that i
mean how did you get excited about food
again tell me what happened i went to um
a casting
and they said that i look like i haven't
been addict oh seriously yeah i thought
i should um
i looked very ill and i should do
something about it guys what did you
weigh then about five and a half six
stone
you're joking yeah [ __ ] i can't
imagine you being five and a half stone
my god
we're looking back at pictures i just
looked awful
do you know what there's maybe burma
blooming onions talking to me oh [ __ ]
house
talk to me anymore they're fine and i'm
not just saying that because i'm gonna
win
they're fine i'm not gonna win you don't
win very often anyway
do you [ __ ] mind excuse me okay
so i'm frying the onions off first and
frying them away they give a little bit
of color and then the mint once you've
got color on the mints we're just gonna
put it in a colander
and just leave it to sit there that
stops a really greasy sort of
film of oil on top of the cottage pie
which i don't want so drain it off it's
fat
and fry off the onions
i've drained the mince and i've used the
um
the water from the carrots to make a
stock
so i'm putting my potatoes back in the
pan basically to dry out
and then we'll put them through what
they call a ricer
and everyone should have one of these at
home have you got one of these at home
no
no what's it do it just pushes the
potatoes posh things that
it's not posh oh it is look and it just
makes sense
there's an ikea
there's no smash oh please
oh i can't believe you said that a very
dry smash finish look how nice and light
and fluffy that is now look
michelle huh so that's too smooth that's
that's too smooth [ __ ] you now
are you always this fussy that's too
smooth look that's beautiful my god look
is that lumpy that mashed potato no
what's that hold on hold on i haven't
finished yet
looks like you've had a [ __ ] cheap
plaster come around to do the bathroom
yeah nick knolls in the house [ __ ] you
know look at you
ah [ __ ] me i don't want a festival it
was this morning that's the state of me
when was the last time you worked this
hard
long time ago i can tell you right we're
going in right we're in the oven yes
cottage pie with michelle collins
shepherd's pie oh [ __ ] here now don't
start that again cottage pie
oh right are you happy with that why not
cappy
right it's in there yes actually it
looks all right yes but let's just hope
it tastes right
[Music]
i'm really passionate about sourcing
fresh local ingredients and you can't
get any more local than that
the [ __ ] river thames running past
your back door
there's nothing more british in the pot
of jelly deals and for hundreds of years
they were our favorite fast food snack
but now they're so unpopular the
wildlife fish industry
is in danger of dying out altogether no
no no no no
that's disgusting they're slimy nobody's
sick
the thames is the cleanest metropolitan
river in the world it's teeming with
life above and below the waterline
including the much maligned eel so why
is dave pierce the only commercial ill
fisherman
left oh really the market has dropped a
lot
and when the market drops the money
drops yep why is it not a trendy thing
to be doing on the thames
because there's so little demand for
eels in britain dave sells his entire
catch to holland
where wild eels are considered a great
delicacy right
how do you catch an eel we're going to
show you shall we yep
i can see him coming through there oh
yeah and now you pull up billy oh
thank you i've never caught a wild deal
dave now
you've got three there by looks of it
okay yeah there's three hills in the
first end nice size there's a big one
though
yeah yeah that's the size you don't want
them too big they're too big to eat if
you're getting too big in there yeah
they're showing yeah
there's a pound and a half come on
two-pound lady it's beautiful look yeah
and that's nearly 20 years old that day
could well be here
thanks dave all right mike good to see
you man
it's crazy that we're ignoring our wild
eels they're part of our culinary
heritage
and i want to make sure that they don't
disappear from our tables
[Music]
first stop frank bradley who after 40
years in the ill business is an expert
in the art of killing eels
apparently it's a bugger of a job how
many years have you been headed oh i
don't know we do three times a week
so it's about three tons of meals a week
yeah so it's a lot of hills
so the secret is what the secret is
when you get older you yeah
that's it then gut then when they're
live like this
that's always trying to turn up here
split the bow and knot that
guard shall we go yeah so down
down straight on on the fins ah for
[ __ ] sake
yeah i'll take the one on the bench
there you go on the side of the fins
there like
on the side of the fence just straight
down oh my god
say
the art is to hold them gently that's it
[Music]
the [ __ ] thing's still moving oh he
still wants to take it's just like a
chicken
unbelievable i mean i was every day i'm
getting past myself by the day your
heels keep me young
you're famed for your jelly deals what's
the secret behind the recipe in terms of
you know jelly deals the only deal is
that the the art of cooking eels is
when they're overcooked they fall apart
yeah but if they're undercooked they're
hard as rocks
and what'd you cook yours in we just
boil them in water and water yeah and
so much comes out and then all you do is
add a little bit of gelatine a little
bit of salt
and then when we get them out so they're
beautiful jelly meals
[Music]
that is delicious the flavor is amazing
huh i'm gonna get these off cook them
and help sort of change the nation's
attitude to something squeamish that can
be
absolutely delicious jelly deals have
been served in london's traditional pie
mash shops for years
daily deals not as popular as i used to
be mate really hopefully i'm gonna
change that i'm gonna do something a
little bit more sort of um not delicate
but just a little bit more
flavor sounds lovely yeah ready yeah
kitchen where is it kitchen's that way
help yourself
now there's more than one way than
cooking an eel and it doesn't have to be
in a jelly
now i'm going to boil them in water and
then coat them with breadcrumbs
almost like a really nice posh fish
finger into the pan
salt pepper two thirds of the way with
water
bring the water up to the boil and then
just poach them
for three or four minutes while we're
waiting for the eels to boil
i'm going to season the breadcrumbs now
that's just normal white breadcrumbs
in here we've got some nice fresh
chopped parsley
salt a teaspoon of cayenne pepper and
some finely grated
nutmeg now drain the eels
once they've been poached get your
butter lightly melted
and then just drop that into the
breadcrumbs this is where the posh fish
finger comes out
pat them nicely and look how sexy is
that into the oven
and then just before we serve them a
drop of fresh lemon juice
there's nothing squeamish about that
bait teal in the herb crust beautiful
not even a hint of slime let's see if
this persuades those winds to give eels
a chance
you're happy with that yeah nice thank
you have you eaten meals before never
tried them why not
because it's just something i've never
even thought about being don't like the
look slime jelly or just yeah probably
it's all that right really yeah as i
thought
take the eel out the jelly and bob's
your uncle i've been fine they're
[ __ ]
beautiful excellent delicious yeah
so what do you think
thank god for that
okay did you enjoy the main course no no
go on
it was like a fedex package in the
middle like that i couldn't get boot
with the knife some sort of like parcel
and when i got in there unpappy never
mind that papi art it was not good
but we've got pictures of that garden i
heard you've got pigs in that garden i
have pictures
are they old sports are they no they're
little baby pigs they're bred to be
small that's sugar pie
that's not a pig it's a little baby
pizza sweet pig and we used to have them
in the house
is it duracell battery people was it a
real pizza it's a lovely sugar pine
she's nice
i pick her up and cuddle her and she she
used to come and sit on my lap while i
was watching doctor who you do
and if it was scary it's a couple of
eyes look there's jack who's our [ __ ] so
having a talk with them
and you leave them outside or well we
did have them living in the house but
unfortunately the smell of piss got too
much even for me
okay did you enjoy the film uh yes i did
enjoy seeing neil from i like it
but i tried cooking some for my wife
once i bought you because she loved you
all fresh
no i didn't my friends i bought it
frozen right and also
it was a couple of days past the sell by
day but i thought that wouldn't be bad
and it smelled like when i got it out
but i thought once i cook it up she
won't notice the rice was perfect
cheapskate the ear wasn't so good and
then i put more sauce on the normal and
shaved it and she was vomiting in the
bath within an hour
but i like that because the view was
spectacular
you're fluent in japanese not fluent
well getting a little bit tsukashi
that's not bad you love japanese cuisine
i love it yes i've got the most amazing
treat for you in the kitchen
by a top japanese eel specialist i'll
wait
you know you'll make me kill it you eat
them you've got to kill the bloody
things i don't know
that's what i play less something to do
right listen it's enough for dizzy
actually jane's going to love it oh she
will and this is an expert
she's just saying she needs to laugh
with this you have to get yourself in
the mood no no no
this man is an expert and he's going to
show us how to prepare an ideal
okay so very gently
pull this away please there you go don't
upset him we're about to kill it
there you how long does it take to
become a skilled eel man
chef is very unique one unique yeah yeah
so
at least five or six years five or six
years yeah they're specialists aren't
they yeah so it's not just like
filleting a normal fish no
no but when you kill it like this does
it feel any pain
i don't think you cannot feel it no then
just don't
because it should be very hard to stay
here being because
you cannot open it you see you just
realized i've got i'm on a parking meter
look i'll see you stay here you win
how can i get cleaned wait don't
yes have you seen this done before no
not in japan
no amazing absolutely amazing never seen
anything like that it's still beating
several hours after oh my goodness look
at that why is he still going what's
your gun
what did did he have a red ball before
you killed him because he was a very
strong creature
um how would you eat that in japan now
still pulsating what would you do just
to put
on your tongue then jonathan what
did you have a bite oh i go on then if
you have someone i'll have some
toss a coin all right oh yes that way
it's fair all right yeah
heads or tails okay
it's still [ __ ] pulsating yeah so how
do you do it just on your tongue
with water i'll do it i'll do it you're
sure
or swallow not chewy just swallow it
without it
then just good
later yes okay thank you very much
right dessert yeah the secret behind the
tatang
is getting a really nice caramelization
on there it's the same with apples
pears even pineapple to a certain extent
yeah
first thing you need is a basic caramel
using butter and sugar
you can do in advance and leave it to
cool so your pans are ready when you are
so plums now like any tatan
try and compact them in there like that
yeah so when they compact like that okay
basically
okay they don't move okay yeah yeah so
there's eight seven or eight six of the
big ones okay
pastry nip it with your fingers at the
end and we do that
to tuck the pastry yeah under the plum
pastry over see and that's wider than
the pan so
over yeah get the back of your spoon
lift up the pastry
lift up the plum and tuck it's really
important to manipulate the pastry with
your fingertips
okay this is even simpler than the
[ __ ] prawn toast
push down tuck the pastry under
that's ready to go you put a little hole
in the center there
okay and that lets the air come out okay
and that stops the plums from
steaming okay into the center of the
stove
yeah and what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna bring it up
on the stove to melt we're not gonna
melt it in the oven okay yeah if we put
in the oven straight away it just boils
it i want to get a really nice color on
there yeah
get the camel really nice and hot now
it's coming up to the top
okay you can see the steam coming
through the little hole there now if we
didn't put the hole in there
it goes soggy underneath and everyone
thinks the pastry is undercooked but
it's not it's just soggy pastry
from there into the oven eight to ten
minutes
oh that's sorry that's the first one
right okay watch
again please be very very careful that
is piping hot out
in oh wow with a juice like that that's
a nice smell for you now
we're getting part of that come fresh
clean bunny right we've got to do that
now judy everyone is capable of doing
that out here that's amazing the plums
have still got a nice texture the
pastry's cooked
it's caramelised yeah let's stick
together on this one
yeah yeah and get 50 customers paying
double for that yes
yes let's go next on the menu i find out
if michelle collins cooks better than al
del zilli
what they say they like both of them but
there is one who
actually they prefer and my student
brigade get their results
okay john baptist hey got it remove the
results
um
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back now judgment time for
michelle collins ready to serve they
don't like nipples actually they do
lower nipples
hello okay first one
very creamy creamy isn't it no i don't i
like the mashed potatoes it's not too
crispy either it's nice
it's a gravy
i actually really like that see this
looks like a cupcake
i prefer the actual look and really
crispy are on the top this time as well
there's no sauce
okay they went down well yes very well
yeah what they say
they like both of them but there is one
who actually they prefer
of course and uh i'm sorry michelle's
gordon yes
i'm sorry yeah yeah they're very close
they thought that gordon's ones were a
bit more flavory the mash was more
uh you know just because they used a
well done my darling but no now do me a
favor yes
yes i'm up to my eyeballs and shake all
right go pop out the kitchen thank you
my darling
good luck okay
[Music]
we take these over to the hot plate
watch
service please table one first yes right
barney come here
yes please cloudy cream in the center
two seconds
in the center
on top they look fantastic by the way
yes
right please uh table one john baptist
yes
clear that way please again please be
careful yes
watch the juice look very very careful
go table one please yes
let's go jump back to stable one let's
go they start sticking
yep okay just release them again on top
of the stove okay
they're beautiful they are fantastic
just worked i thought it was really
soggy and really sour
as like at all the pastry was sweet
the plums were a bit bitter and it just
worked perfectly i absolutely adored it
i'm going to 100 pay for that course
i like this you like that yes was that
butter or cream on top
uh no that was a like a clotted cream a
devonshire cream nice rich i like that
yes what about the tart the plum tart
it's not eel hard but it's not bad
jean-baptiste
yeah come here please yes john right
this is getting more and more like jimmy
carr every time i see him
okay ah this is this has been grilled
oil
by the way joe baptist is french there's
no point in talking japanese to you know
that you say
he's not friendly from vermont
[Music]
that is good that's good very good
you know he hasn't overdone the sauce
often you get when you go to a knots
it's a good japanese restaurant
they'll overdo that sauce on top which
is quite a rich like sweet sauce yeah
japanese pepper i ate his pulsating
heart and then i'm feasting on his flesh
an amazing delicacy are you happy with
that this is good i can eat this until
the cows come home and you've started
them good to see you
i'm glad you're going to pay for dinner
you're tight bastard some of it come on
all of it
come on you're not short of a penny well
[Applause]
[Music]
done
okay john baptist right got it what's
the results
18 are paying and 32 are not paying 32
not paying yeah it's ridiculous
quite a lot yeah why uh the main reason
is it's too acidic it's not sweet enough
it's a new season plan for god's sake
they're just philistines yeah well
let's have a quick look overall okay 83
paid out of 150 plates that's not even a
[ __ ] 2-2 tommy is it no
no no no no no ah if you're in my
[ __ ] kitchen all four we've got
sacked
after the [ __ ] prawn toast now will
you do me a favor [ __ ] off over there
and get a drink yes
absolutely
you